[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
whose new neighbor is being abused and
she wants to know how to handle it we
also talked to a woman who lost a
newborn child she's pregnant she wants
to know how to grieve and experience joy
we talked to a couple with a big win
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john delony show and we're
already yelling so unnecessarily hey we
have a whole crew out here today
normally
there's just like one sad person whose
uber hasn't picked him up yet and now we
got a bunch of folks it's good to see
everybody
smiling and looking
remarkable beautiful and handsome and
wonderful
they're even pulling up chairs tables
great good to see everybody kelly it's
good to be see ya
it's nice to be back thank you very much
watch it
here's my day here's my day
so i was on a
like i planned this father-son event for
me and my son we went on this crazy
no just crazy hunt with a buddy's a
therapist and his name's matt he's just
one of those he's extraordinary we went
hunting this weekend
nothing
zero things zero things we even saw we
just spent
72 hours in a tree
staring off into space
and then we got up before
the sun this morning before earth was
even spinning and then we raced back i
got pulled over
and the police officer said do you know
how fast you're going and i was like way
way too fast
he started laughing
and uh
then
i got home
kelly i'm gonna make a confession
um i think last week
this is hard for me to say over the the
internet but here we go
last week
um
i was doing something at my house and i
dropped something and i bit done to pick
it up and i split my pants
i split them oh we're not we're just
getting going
i was like what how do you split your
pants like i'm i work out all the time
man so then i was going to go out into
the woods for a while so i put on my uh
in the woods pants
bent down to tie the shoe split them
both and this is about 20 minutes apart
from pant to pant
and now i feel the universe saying i
should get an elliptical or so i got to
do something different
and then today
i was grabbing some water to go to a
meeting and i spilt some on the floor
and i bent down
split these pants
right now
i would show you if we didn't have an hr
department they are split right down
like uncomfortably so
i'm sitting in this chair all of me
where are you buying your pants from
they're they're real nice pants no it's
clearly a me problem clear this is not a
gene's problem this is a john pro i
think it's a gene problem we'll see
i'm origin g i'm going to call get
jocko's jeans i they won't so then the
show's kept starting
and i walk in
and kelly comes in here all wild and
drunk or whatever's going on
and
this is a picture i have on the shelf in
here of
four of my oldest friends in the world
pausing caleb and ryan me
i think this was at my wedding
it used to be
have glass
but kelly got mad and fit on the floor
and now there's glass everywhere
got a vacuum what are you doing
first of all
the vacuum was not my idea let's be very
very clear
is there any this is james idea is there
any more man response to broken glass
like i don't get a vacuum no no no
james's response was first let's sweep
it up and that was mine and i look over
and you decide to run the vacuum no
james got to vacuum
with a slew of broken glass so now it's
even worse than it was yeah i made it
way worse i made it way worse but
i did i didn't drop the picture i sent
the picture i slammed it on anger and it
fell off but the frame was already
broken when you brought it in you got to
take ownership i did it fell off but the
frame was already broken
so it needed wasn't me dude it was
gravity yeah it was time for this why we
can't have nice things this is
aren't you glad to have me back where
did we even get this
i didn't even know it was in there
well
you do now and it's full there's glass
there's glass everywhere hey quick tip
boys and girls do not
drive over glass with a vacuum it just
shoots it everywhere
i think most people already know like a
long like a leaf blower oh do they i
think so i think it's kind of a heads up
would have been cool so thanks for that
i just thought james as the executive
producer of like one of the biggest
shows on earth with not this one by the
way he produces another one definitely
not this show uh but i thought you would
know how to clean up broken glass my
exact words were let me go try to find a
broom in a dust pan and i walked out of
the room and i came back in and you were
vacuuming
and it sounded awful yeah it wasn't
great it wasn't great
oh man so i think after so far today i
think the best thing we can do is
help other people with their lives let's
try let's give that a shot let's go to
jessica in miami what's up jessica
hi dr john how are you
we're getting there i'm glad to talk to
you because so far today has been
a disaster but we're gonna we're right
in the ship today so thank you for
calling what's up how can i help of
course sure
um i just moved to a completely new city
and i'm making friends and i made
friends with the girl
and she confided in me that her husband
is abusing her
and i don't know
what to do or how to help
and so tell me about it
so i met this girl um in the dog park
she seemed super super nice and she
invited me out to dinner
so i went out to dinner with her and
another girl that lives here
and basically
um we just we're all married so you know
we got into the conversation about like
our husbands and stuff
and she kind of
um she was kind of telling us that she
was like really unhappy in her marriage
and
i was kind of uncomfortable because i
don't really
i didn't really know her and like i
you know i didn't really kind of want to
engage too much in the conversation
because she's kind of a stranger and
my husband is kind of great and i didn't
want to like
you know i didn't want to like such a
because my husband's awesome
i didn't really have anything to
contribute and then she flat out told it
told us that um
he was like manipulating her um
financially mentally and then i had just
i don't know i just had this weird like
inkling to ask the question
and i said well does he does he hit you
and she she said yes
and um then she told us that um
while she's sleeping that he
rapes her while she's sleeping
and i
i just
i don't know like
i don't know what to do um after that
dinner happened i um
i was outside on my balcony one night
and i saw the police roll in and i saw
them like drive kind of towards where
she lives
and i didn't really think too much of it
um because you know we live in a huge
complex a lot of people kind of crazy
here you know
and um like 30 minutes after that
happened she came to my apartment she
knocked on the door and she said that um
some one of her neighbors called the
police on her because
they heard um they heard her yelling
good for them and
that um
they came to look for her her husband
but he wasn't there and she just said
you know um you know the police are here
and i don't know what to do and he's not
here i just i don't know like i don't
know what advice i can offer a stranger
yeah um and i i
and honestly and i'm not trying to you
know i've never dealt with something
like this so i i don't know even how to
like react or i don't even know how to
hang out with her
right or like be there and you know yeah
um but i want to like i want to i i just
don't know like how involved do you get
in these things like what do you say how
do i protect myself if he's like
you know she there certain things she
said she has said and done has kind of
like
makes me feel like they're both a little
unstable and they both might be a little
unsafe and it makes me uncomfortable to
a certain extent but i don't want to
like
isolate myself or make her feel bad or
be like a bad friend but is she even my
friend because i just met her i have a
lot of questions so number one thanks
for sharing that and um
man welcome to your new house right
yeah exactly
you may have heard me say this line
before and it sounds kind of like a line
if you will but um
uh
you ever heard me say not by your hand
but in your lap
yes
so that's one of these situations
where
you were hanging out with a couple of
new friends at an apartment complex and
then somebody dropped something in your
lap that now you've got to deal with
um and
there's a couple of different facets to
this number one
you're not going to be friends with
every new person that you meet and what
i mean by friends like when i say
friends i mean like someone you're going
to tell the good stuff to and the bad
stuff too and
who hurt you and you're going to he
right it's your 2 a.m people right
we only have a few of those and but
you're also going to be a neighbor and
we're all neighbors
so
this
you're in a weird spot because it feels
good to have somebody tell you all this
stuff right and i don't know what to do
with it all is that fair
yeah fair
so
you're going to have to
stop accepting stuff that you aren't
equipped to handle and you're gonna have
to be very very clear about a boundaries
and b what you're gonna do next
okay
so if i'm in your situation here's how
i'm gonna handle that
um
if somebody tells me something really
heavy
i will ask are you inviting me to for my
opinion are you are you asking me for
what are you asking for me when they
when somebody says like hey i'm gonna
hurt myself or hey i'm i'm being abused
whatever um
are you inviting me into this
conversation that's the first thing so
i'm gonna like we're done with the
pleasantries there i'm now we're in
action mode okay the second thing is is
i'm gonna let them know you've got 24 or
48 hours to call
the non-emergency line
um of the local police department or i'm
going to call
or i am calling in 48 hours and i'll be
with you when you make your report but
you've told me some stuff that i'm not
equipped to handle and i can't let
somebody in my apartment complex be hurt
that's different than you know my
husband won't give me the checkbook back
and he drinks too much i mean some of
that kind of stuff is
that's i mean if they're not inviting
you into that they're just people are
just spitballing at a bar that's that's
one thing but for me my line is when it
gets into violence
then i'm not going to have that on my
conscience
i'm not going to have somebody in my
neighborhood who's said i'm con i'm
being hurt in the present i'm not gonna
i'm gonna do what i can at least right
that's right um and you don't have an
obligation to hang out
you don't have an obligation to say yes
you can have your boundaries too
okay does that feel weird
yeah you know what it's just
it's weird for me because i feel like i
um
i've had like the same friends my whole
entire life yeah
and i'm in this new place where i don't
really know anyone and i
since i have had the same friends my
entire life i always feel this
weird obligation to like
get involved does that make sense and
because i don't really know anything
anything else like
my friendships are very
like the ones that i have are very i
guess deep and i've had them my whole
life literally the same people
in my life my whole life so this person
like i meet this person and i am
automatically like i'm like okay like
what can i
you know what can i do to help what can
i you know
how can i
even if it makes me uncomfortable yes
because
your quasi-co-dependent is that fair
yeah yeah oh yeah for sure yes don't be
you're like just so dismissive that's
that's so rude
um
when
it feel
it feels like almost like a live netflix
series you're in now
and what i need you to hear me say is
this is super visceral and super real
and it feels like oh my gosh this is
like one of those murder podcasts that
kelly listens to like it feels like i'm
in a thing now right i'm in a thing
this is real world
someone's getting beat up right across
the hall
right and so i'm going to make that
phone call and i'm going to let somebody
know i don't believe in the in the
grenade throwing in the spring you know
what i mean um okay i'm gonna i just
need you to know this is coming i'm
gonna let this happen um and she can
here's that thing she can do because
she's an adult she can lie
when the non-emergency police officer
comes out the detective comes out
somebody comes out to see if she's okay
the social worker whatever crisis team
they've got shows up she can lie to him
and say no i'm great everything's fine
i'm all good
so what do i do when because um
it's i told her we had another
conversation and i said listen i if i
like if you come to me and like he's
hitting you or any anything like that or
you know something happened i'm gonna
call the police because i i do feel like
this is completely over my head and i'm
you know not equipped to handle these
things
um
and i feel like since i've said that
she's kind of like pulled back a little
bit and that's her hey that's i know you
want to get
you want to her to like don't pull back
keep telling me everything
you put up a boundary and your boundary
is i'm calling the cops
and then she gets to respond to your
boundary you did right okay
okay where you're gonna make this messy
is if you go fishing
right yeah and i don't want to do that
but but you do want to do that you know
it's just not good
yeah yeah yeah of course like inside
inside i'm like but i but i want you to
tell me but i also have my own issues
and my own family and my own husband and
i just i can't yes i i can't do it yes
and so don't go fishing
don't go fishing
okay you put up your boundaries you let
her know hey i'm a person in this
apartment complex
we just met you're kind you're nice cool
um yeah if i hear you're getting beat up
and abused i'm calling
and here's another thing this isn't
always this is rare but there's always
another side to a story
right so you got one piece of a story
one night at a bar from somebody that
you've come to find out
maybe embellish this stuff right you
said she's a little bit like i don't
know right who knows
um so you don't know the full picture
that's why i'm calling the the
authorities and i'm gonna let them sort
this out
right um if she comes to you in the
middle of the night obviously screaming
and scared of course you call that one
what you know all that stuff
but i don't want you getting your
self-esteem off trying to solve your new
neighbor's problems
okay and this is going to sound weird
like if you
if
like if you dated somebody a long time
and then you
start dating somebody new you kind of
you just kind of started from square one
right
it's very similar to your friends you've
had the same friends for a long long
time i so applaud you what a stud for
going out and like trying to make
friends that's so rad
it's the only way to have a healthy life
is to go awkward and risk and you and it
went sideways right um anything goes
sideways actually somebody can fight on
you i'm gonna take that back it didn't
go sideways somebody confided in you
they they told you it was on their heart
and now you gotta you know you're in the
middle of it um
keep risking okay
keep reaching out to people even if it's
hard even if it's wonky even if this one
ends up you know
she didn't tell the truth or she didn't
tell the truth and now you're going to
be somebody who really helped be a part
of saving her life and which is noble
and good um
but yeah don't be reliant on her and her
drama and her what feels like a netflix
show
like i can't wait to know what comes
next no you don't want to know what
comes next and call the authorities and
let them take care of it if she reaches
out to you again say what do you want me
to do with this information
how can i love you how can i support you
but i ain't but just know part of my
love and support is calling people who
know what they're doing when it comes to
this stuff
she's lucky to have you i'm glad you're
asking the right questions we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos
i've reached out and there's a six month
waiting list or i can't afford it or
they only take insurance i can't get off
work and time to go see somebody and
it's way across town what do i do
because i want help with my anxiety my
depression my relationships are hanging
on by a thread i want to be a better mom
i gotta process this trauma that
happened to me when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to leslie
in
grand rapids michigan what's up leslie
hey how you doing we were just rocking
onto the break of dawn what about you
living the dream are you what is that
nightmare is it good there you go
there you go more of a nightmare so
what's going on yeah
uh well i appreciate you taking my call
of course thanks for calling
so i got a tough one i'm gonna do my
best not to be emotional because i
really want to hear what you have to say
hey be as emotional as you need to you
can always go back and listen
so
my husband and i
lost our daughter to cancer
uh seven months ago
yikes nine months old holy smokes
yep wow what was your name what was your
name
sadie sadie nine months
yup
what kind of cancer uh
she was born with leukemia
god almighty so is it in utero
yeah but we didn't know until she was
about five months old so she fought for
about four months and
it just became too much for treatment
oh my gosh that little bitty baby
yeah so we have a lot going on in our
lives and um so that was did you say
seven months ago
yeah it was seven months ago okay so
just pause right there
what's the last seven months been how
are you and your husband doing
um you know it's a struggle every day
for sure um
you know everybody else goes on with
their lives and it still seems like
we're stuck yeah
yep you know we're still doing our thing
and going to work and just trying to put
one foot in front of the other
i've i've found
that after month four
five or six or so
when the calls stop and the tech stop
and the casserole stop
that's when that
grief becomes heavy heavy heavy and
really dark gray
right yeah is it fair is that what
you're experiencing
yeah it's it's definitely uh
similar to that it's very difficult
for sure
so then you say that's not all what's
next
no
so on top of that
um i'm actually currently pregnant
four months pregnant with our soon-to-be
son
wow
we have a lot going on yeah
wow wow wow okay
yeah and so all signs pointing to
healthy everything good with sun
um
so far but they won't be able to test
him for cancer until he's born
so
okay
i'm gonna put a pin in what you just
said okay and then we'll circle back to
it all right but i don't remember this
moment cause i'm gonna bring it back up
okay
okay all right so keep going
all right um so a couple questions that
i have for you is
how do we process our feelings of our
grief while simultaneously allowing
ourselves to feel joy for this new child
that's coming
we find ourselves you know the outside
world is
so happy for us and it makes it seem
like they think that this new baby is
gonna
you know make us happy again and solve
our problems and
it's hard to be excited
you know when we're still grieving
and then my other question was
how do we
more so probably for me i don't know
about my husband but how do we process
our fear of our new baby being a
constant reminder of the baby that we
lost yeah
do you have any other kids
no this was our first first child okay
um can i ask you a few questions before
we dig in
yeah okay
um this isn't always but sometimes often
um
i've sat with women who blame themselves
or like my body did this thing
um do you have any sort of self-blame
here or do you understand that the rare
just struck by lightning nature of some
of this
no yeah i don't i don't feel that um
good good her cancer was a chromosomal
thing and not a genetic thing okay um so
it just was
in the cards for her okay
which is both a relief and terrifying
because she's in the cards for all of us
right and that
it it brings
to light how precious every single
breath is right
right
um okay so
a couple of things
number one
i want you to separate
these two
kids
and right now with this pregnancy being
on top of what feels like just such a
recent pregnancy and everything is so
charged it feels like one constant
stream like one continuous
um
continuous day
and it's two separate people
okay yeah
and i know that's hard but it's
something i want you to lean towards
because when you lean into that a little
bit it will be there will become
there'll be a light that comes through
the crack between the two
okay and that's how you're gonna you're
gonna honor
and love sadie
you're gonna remember sadie you're gonna
see the bravery and you're gonna talk
about her bravery and how she fought and
those precious moments you had when she
grabbed your finger those things that
you know you can still feel that
pressure on your finger right you still
feel it
and
you're going to be able to
celebrate your son
as two separate events it it feels like
right now that all you're gonna think
about is and what i'm telling you on the
other side of having two kids it feels
that way and it's gonna be different
okay you will remember sadie you'll
remember the experience you'll remember
the fear
and so earlier when i asked you how is
he healthy your answer was so far
because here's what you're doing now now
you're waiting for the next shoe to drop
my guess is
you haven't fully exhaled since you
found out you were pregnant is that fair
yeah that's fair okay
so
have you and your husband
you know i say this all the time and and
um
it's not a catch-all but man it's such a
gift have you and your husband written
say to you a letter
um no not nothing like that okay
so what i want both of you to do is i
want your husband to write sadie a
letter
one page two page ten pages
i want him to tell her
about his childhood i want him to tell
her about how excited he felt when he
found out that y'all were having a baby
when he found out i was gonna be a girl
um
i want him to write to sadie and tell
him how scared he was when he found out
that she was sick
how
brave he thought she was um and this is
a
this could be a one letter it could be a
couple of letters um it might be hey
here is here's i just want you to get to
know your dad
and it could be hey uh here's what i
experienced when you weren't doing well
i want you to know how much i loved you
and i know you're only seven months old
six months old five months old but
here's what i was experiencing
and
then on the back end here's how much i
miss you i just want you to know that i
miss you right and i want you to do the
same thing
and then i want you all to read your
letters to each other
okay
grief has a way of splitting people up
because everybody grieves differently
how's your marriage right now
our marriages is good um
i think the fact that you know we were
the only ones that could be there for
her and we're the only ones that got to
experience
the situation
we lean on each other in that way
because nobody else understands what we
went through right have you joined a
group uh grief group with parents who've
lost young kids
um no okay you know i haven't really
found any yet but i i i relate to you oh
so strongly recommend that you do that
okay
i won't walk through my personal stuff
but i'll tell you it's having
conversations with folks has been a
lifeline for me
yeah okay
um
it's so so so important i didn't
experience near what you experienced but
loss of losses losses loss and i'll tell
you is having people that you can just
like you just said it you talk to them
and they go yeah i get it i know and
they talk to you back and you go oh gosh
you know you know what i mean and it
makes you feel a little bit less alone
which makes your
brain calm down just a little bit and
then you can be a little more open and
you can breathe a little bit more deeply
and it begins to that's the road the
path to healing
okay yeah
and then
i want you and your husband to write
letters to this new little boy
about how excited you are here's what
i'm telling you to do and it's gonna
sound bonkers i want you to go all in on
him
because what you're
man i get emotional think about this
you're going to want to hedge your bets
right
don't do that go all in on him risk
getting
hurt again like you were last time
because it's prob statistically speaking
it's not going to happen right
i mean we hope
see there you go
now you are waiting for the next thing
to happen and what i'm telling you is
statistically speaking it's not gonna
happen again
you're gonna have a wonderful excited
joyful
bonkers little baby boy
pooping and peeing and yelling
everything and
you know what i mean
exactly what you hoped for
don't hedge your bets this is your baby
is your child go all in and i want you
and your husband to share in
that fear
i'm nervous and i'm scared and also that
joy it's okay to feel joy it feels like
joy
for your new son
is like you're
cheating on you're abandoning your
daughter
and they're not mutually exclusive
like you know what i mean like it feels
like if you're joyful you're like oh
this is going to be so great that
somehow you're disrespecting your
daughter does it feel that way right
yeah i mean i understand completely what
you're saying tell me in your own words
i just feel like you know each day that
moves on and
each experience that we move forward
with it's just like another step
away from her yeah
so here's what i want you to do
are you listening leslie
yep i want you to let her go
she's gonna stay a part of you she
always will
always always will
but once you let go
and it's going to take time that's going
to take healing
it is not a disrespe it's not
disrespectful to her it's not a sign
that you are leaving her if you
experience joy if you laugh
if you
cheer and are excited about your new son
it's both and
yeah because you're going to love sadie
for the rest of your life
that tough powerful strong beautiful
little girl's gonna be with you forever
i appreciate that
i'm telling you
you don't trust me dude i know you don't
trust me it's okay though
no you don't you don't have to
you're that far
you don't have to um
you don't have to i just want you to
know
joy will come again
yeah
is there like a way to like process the
trauma of you know what we saw visually
and
you know how to
not be have that like be a constant
reminder like every day of what we went
through yeah so is there like a
yeah there's several techniques i'm
gonna give you the high level one okay
probably you're gonna um if you get uh
caught on looping thoughts on that
rumoring thoughts of i remember that
baby were you with her when she passed
away
yeah and it wasn't a it wasn't a
peaceful death by any means that's right
and that haunts you
yeah
and often when we think about loved ones
that we lost especially children
we think about them now
as though they're still experiencing the
last moment that we held them
right and sadie's at peace
right now she's at
that last moment you spent with her that
ugliness and that grittiness and that
terror
it's over
okay
the the top level high level
um is it's from david kessler just the
grief master i'd recommend at some point
maybe not now but you and your husband i
want you to read finding meaning
together we'll link to it in the show
notes it's the single greatest book on
grief i've ever read
um and it's about the loss of a child
okay
um
but he gives this example and i've done
it on the show i haven't done it in a
while but he asks everybody in the
audience an audience of parents who've
lost a child
to
imagine i think it was a purple elephant
he said picture a purple elephant in
your mind
and then they have in their mind and
then he tells them to open their eyes
and he says there i proved it to you you
can control your thoughts
here's what happens
we get that picture that just lightning
bolts into our mind
of those last two minutes those last six
minutes says last two months
the moment they lightning bolt into our
head
we have a choice
am i gonna meditate on that on the
terror on the fear on my tears on that
how scary it all was or
am i going to remember
holding her
and i going to remember the quiet nights
the
time in front of the fire the
breastfeeding nights the time she was
bouncing with dad and laughing a little
bit am i going to remember that
and you get to choose which one of those
and over time if you just like my wife
she'll hear me i'll walk through the
living room i'll be like nope that means
something popped into my head and i'm
just telling my body i'm not doing it
i'm not doing it and she'll laugh like
she'll be like oh gosh john she doesn't
even ask me what it was she doesn't want
to know what it but i'm conscious about
i'm not going to meditate on that
i'm not going to let that just loop in
my head i'm going to have a picture
that's going to replace it and so you
can picture those last couple of minutes
in the hospital
or you can picture you can go nope i'm
not thinking of that i'm thinking of
this
and what i'll tell you is over time your
body when you conju when you think of
sadie
it will bring back the pictures that you
tell it to that you meditate on and it
will default not to the hard stuff
because the hard stuff just trying to
remind you hey this happened this could
happen again it could happen again it
could happen again
and you can train your brain
we're remembering beauty
we're remembering joy
and it's a battle for a while and it's
hard because you feel like you're
letting your daughter go and i'm telling
you let her go she's gonna be with you
whether you
she's gonna be with you she's a part of
you
let her go
thank you okay
i appreciate it we love you leslie and
i'm so so sorry
but
you and your husband write those letters
y'all read them to each other
and then i want you to each write a
letter about how excited you are to meet
your son
if you're brave i want you to mail me a
copy of that letter
or email me a copy of that letter
and if you don't want me to read on the
air i won't if you do i'd love to
because i'd love to let everybody know
how i would love everybody here
[Music]
the words of a mom who's both
brokenhearted and both brimming with
optimism and joy a mom who's both
terrified of the next shoe that's going
to drop and both hopeful
i'd love to read that letter out it
would bless
there's not a lot of people listening to
the show but actually you know what i'm
not even making a joke of this one it
would bless a lot a lot of people a lot
of people listen to the show it would
really be a gift
thank you for your bravery leslie we're
worth man i'm thinking about you and
your family we'll be right back i'm dr
john dolone's show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 mmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back and
we got a couple of hard calls on the
show and i want to end on a
with a different kind of call
a
optimism a positive call a call about
bravery and um somebody that had the
opportunity to meet a few times in
person
and i thought
last time we talked i was like man i
gotta get you on the show
so um
let's hear let's go to nicole in
milwaukee hey nicole what's going on
great not much we're excited to uh chat
with you i'm excited to chat with you
thank you so much so nicole i'm gonna
recount the story best i can remember it
and then you can tell me where i screwed
up the story and then jump in from there
okay
yes sir finally so
uh maybe a year ago ish you and your
husband came to an event here in
nashville that me and some of my
colleagues were speaking at
and at that event i gave a talk i think
it was about anxiety or about just
getting your life right i don't remember
exactly about you can you can fill me in
on which talk it was i gave but
um
you and your husband left that event and
it wasn't just my talk by the way it was
several people but you you left that
event and you and your husband got super
super inspired
and so a couple of days after new year's
um
i want to i wanted to bring this show up
here right because this is like we're
just the show's going to air january 6th
um right after new year's people have
already blown their new year's
resolutions
and then here's nicole who changed
everything and then i saw you at another
event months later i didn't recognize
you
so i'll let you pick up the story here
tell everybody what happened
yeah so
so we did we got we got really serious
about um losing weight and
we've been overweight for decades like
serious decades through
infertility struggles and all kinds of
stuff just you know we weren't able to
have kids on our own we had to use a
surrogate because we weren't able to um
i wasn't able to carry a baby naturally
and so
it's always been something that's been
an issue and when you say when you say
overweight what give everybody a picture
of what that means so it's like pretty
significantly overweight um you know i
have like probably 150 pounds to lose
i'm about halfway through where i'm you
know where i want to be to get to my
goal weight
um but i was
you know i think like most people
you think
it's never going to happen it's
impossible i've been this way for
decades that you know all of the things
that
you know you just think about and it's
so hard and it's
i just don't think it's going to happen
well
um but we got really serious about it we
we even had weight loss
surgery scheduled in las vegas
for both my husband and myself and we
got intervened in that
and the surgery place actually canceled
my surgery for me
and so we you know said okay what are we
supposed to do we were you know in our
mindset i think that was a huge thing
that changed was
i think the value of a weight loss
surgery and we did not have weight loss
surgery but the value is that
for the first time you have hope and you
you can envision your life
differently
and for the first time in 20 years i
actually envisioned
what it would be like to be a healthy
weight or to be dinner or to be more
active or to spend time with my daughter
and be able to do fun things and run and
you know just all of those things so my
mind changed first you got a new picture
right yeah right when that changed then
as soon as the weight loss surgery kind
of got pulled out it was like oh man now
i want what my mind had projected for
myself
and how am i going to make that happen
and so it was amazing to me just the
journey that my mind went on in between
those couple of months
and then you know
god as he does drops a plan
right into your lap and so um i actually
texted two of my friends and said hey
the weight loss surgery was canceled
and within 30 seconds both of them came
back to me with the same plan wow hey
we've had friends who have been
successful at this and i'm like okay i
hear you like this makes sense and so we
started this journey on the day that we
were supposed to um have weight loss
surgery what day was that and
may 20th is when we started so
wow so yeah so it's been amazing yeah my
husband tony he lost
about 120 pounds i've lost 70.
yeah so wow that's all that's under 200
pounds that's you all two together
you've lost me i don't exist anymore
that's right i'm a big guy you have lost
me
wow
okay yeah okay you're so amazing
i'm just kind of speechless that's so
incredible for a couple of reasons
number one
you were going
you were going to do surgery and that
got cancelled most people see that as a
sign
this is not going to happen
right they get up they get up the nerve
to whatever the thing is
um well they're going to go get surgery
they're going to go
they're going to finally go to rehab
they're going to finally go to
counseling they're going to finally have
that hard conversation something comes
up that delays that
and
i mean people just say like hey that's
the cosmos saying it's time for me to
i'm not doing this it's not not now i'll
do it later whatever
and you said no no no i have a picture
of nicole in my head playing with her
with my daughter with her daughter
that's happening
and dude you like it's like you showed
up to take a road that everyone was
traveling and they told you the road's
closed and you said fine tony grab the
machetes we're heading off into the
woods we're doing this on our own and
you guys took off so what has been the
hardest part about this journey this
this
this delony evaporation plan you've lost
190 pounds gal
that's a lonely evaporation plan i love
it um
honestly
and this is going to sound crazy but
there actually hasn't really been a hard
spot that hasn't it hasn't been hard all
of the thoughts that i had in my mind
about how hard it was going to be and
all of the
negative imprints that i've had for
years
once i set my mind to do it
and we followed a plan it wasn't we
didn't just do this you know randomly we
followed a we followed a plan with a
program and we just said this is what
we're going to do and this is how we're
going to live and the weight just
started coming off and then as the
weight comes off your confidence
increases
you know you feel more active you
and i think the biggest thing is that
you know it's now possible you know i
think so many people
you know especially this time of year
you know you lose
five ten pounds something you hit a
plateau you fall off the wagon all of
those things
um i think having tony
and we supporting each other um we've
had other people that have seen our
transformation and now have joined along
with us yeah
you're starting a gang nicole you and
tony
uh people who are sick and tired of
being sick and tired man they're done
with the crap that's so incredible
so yeah and it's just it's so worth it
like if i could if i could
tell someone you know i mean that for
years i would think to myself
man if i could only get to where i want
to be and then i could feel what it was
like to be in that body and feel the
benefits of it it would make it that
would give me my why right
um and so i've always felt that way and
so now to be
and i'm still only halfway to my goal
like i still have a long way to go tony
still got a ways to go too and it is
let's be honest it's super annoying
99 times out of 100 it's super annoying
when married couples do this because men
drop weight so fast
oh yeah is that drugs totally
it's the worst but but it's also such a
good thing because
he's i mean like we're sleeping better
we're um eating dinner we're enjoying
life more we're doing so many more
activities and more actions and are
enjoying our daughter we just went to
disney we just got back
and
you know it was just
totally transformational to go from
where we were when we went in march and
where we where we are now
and to just see the difference in just
us walking through the parks and
not getting tired and not wanting to sit
down and you know being able to be on
all the rides and really engage with her
i mean
with our daughter it's just it's
it's it's an amazing transformation and
it's so worth it but i think the first
step is just your mind
and getting it
getting it into the spot where you
believe it's possible
because that's the hardest thing is just
you know we've just
time is told you know it work it works
for a minute but then it stops working
you know and just all these things
builds up
when you get the right plan and you get
the right pass man
the door just opens up and you're on the
highway and it just happens this happens
that's just a cool thing i've heard this
over and over again um
often people get goals
and they should have them we should have
goals they should be measurable they
should be clear they should be
attainable we should put a date on it
like those are all good we should have
goals i want to lose this much weight i
want to lose this much weight by this
time i want to finish this degree by
this year i want to have counseling by
the time i fill in the blank like we all
have those goals
but more important in my mind then the
goal is the plan
because if i just get up every day
if we just get up every day and work the
plan just do the plan
just do the plan
the weight has a way of taking care of
itself is that right
absolutely absolutely it does yes
i found that if i'm trying to like when
i'm trying like when i try to cut weight
for whatever like whatever
i would do crazy things to try to cut
weight i would fast for 48 hours i would
do this or that or try this supplement
i didn't quit working the plan trying to
cut corners to make a number instead of
saying you know what dude i'm like you
said
my goal here the reason i'm losing this
weight is because i want to play with my
daughter i want to be able to walk
through
um disney i want to be able to whatever
that is
it's not just to get that number and so
i'm just gonna work the plan work the
plan on days when it's boring and those
boring days turn into boring months and
those boring months turn into a year i'm
gonna keep working the plan and then
then suddenly you and your husband are
no longer carrying me around your home
and around disney
190 pounds and you say you're halfway
halfway home
yeah halfway there yeah i want to lose
about another seven
he's i don't know that he's got that
much maybe he's got another 70 pounds to
lose so we probably have about the same
together
um that we have to go but
yeah we you know and the cool thing is
we're going to do it because we know of
course you are now now it's a part of
your life right it's just a part of your
life exactly so have you all had
any what i call roadblocks meaning have
you had i guess you had this little
thing called cove that happened have you
all had things that pop up that normally
you would have gone back to food
normally you would have gone back to
netflix and y'all work together to get
through those seasons tell me about one
of those
yeah i mean absolutely it's so easy and
i'm not saying we've been perfect on
this lord knows we haven't um
but the trick is is that if we've
deviated we've always got back up
so
and i think that's where the rubber
meets the road in this is that it's real
easy to fall off of a plan
but
if you can get back on and you say okay
that you know that happened it's okay
and i think a lot of people like beat
themselves up over it we don't do that
we just say listen we were living in
moderation
in that moment
and so if we if we go off plan if we if
we do something you know have something
we shouldn't have we get right back on
it because that is what moderation is
and our body can handle it and and we
understand what our limits and our
boundaries are now
and so that's been very helpful but
communication has obviously been a big
part of it you know if one of us is
feeling like i really want something and
the other person's like here's where we
are and here's where we're going that
can be very empowering and very helpful
so
um you know and if your spouse like i
have my spouse in this with me and
that's obviously very helpful but if you
don't have a spouse
find somebody else to do it with you
um you know half the
people in my office are doing it now and
so that's also very helpful because
we're all in the same boat and we're all
understanding the same
urges and cravings and we want this but
we also want our goals more than we want
whatever the junk we want to put in our
bodies so one last question i want to
ask you um
often when people make a change like
this that's this substantial
and again i've keep throwing out
different changes people make i'm gonna
quit
um i'm gonna choose to heal from my
depression my bipolar disorder i'm gonna
go get help i'm gonna stop being so
anxious and i'm gonna work on
my relationships and whatever the thing
is i'm gonna lean into this thing
there's a season of
where you have to take ownership
there's a season of
owning reality and owning reality for
most of us is a season of grief
i let it get like this
or this happened to me i experienced
exclusion or abuse or people left behind
or whatever
and ultimately here i am or i should
have done this 20 years ago i feel so
great i can't believe i've wasted 20
years in this other body but how have
you and your husband ex worked through
the grief and i know people don't talk
about that they always want to talk
about the fireworks and the ah confetti
falling from the sky but anybody who's
gone through the transformation you have
has experienced some sort of some sort
of reality check somewhat of grief have
y'all dealt with that
yeah i mean we definitely have the whole
you know why did i stay this way for 20
years thing definitely has been
something that's played in my mind
and i think it's appreciating the
journey that we were on and that that
portion of the journey had a purpose in
my life
it makes me more empathetic it makes me
more understanding i now see people who
are the same size i was
and all i want to do is reach out and
help them yeah you want to hug them
instead of instead of judging them right
yeah exactly and i remember what it was
like to feel invisible
and to feel like you know
like i would rather be in my house
than be out in the real world and i and
i remember what that feels like and so
all i want to do is find people who are
in the same situation that i was in and
say hey let me walk alongside you in
this journey and help you
and that's really it i mean
nicole there's so many opportunities
your gift because here's why i'm mapping
it out
you acknowledge the stories the ones you
were born into the ones you told
yourself for so many years i can't do
this it's just the way this is
it's just i'm already this big so i
don't have another thing i've got a
husband here he's on board with like
you owned reality you took you
acknowledged your reality you first you
own those stories you acknowledge
reality and then
you said dude i'm gonna change
everything i'm changing my relationships
i'm gonna change my thoughts i'm gonna
change my actions
and then here you are however many
months later
and you are down 190 pounds as a couple
75 pounds
incredible
and by you being brave and
coming back you came all the way back to
nashville to meet me and met with dave
and
and being brave now to tell everybody
your story you're inspiring people who
five days in six days into 2022 have
already said you know what screw it
okay 2020 knocked me down 2021 kicked my
butt all over the place or i just ran
like a
like a mess like i was just [ __ ] and
running around running around
it kicked my whatever dude i'm fine just
gonna be what it's gonna be
doesn't have to be that way it doesn't
have to be that way
if you're listening to this
you can
whatever it is
you can
and nicole thank you and tony for
sharing your journey with us thank you
for your bravery thank you for getting
up and getting after it and being
awesome
taking no excuses no more like no more
right
let's get give one last charge to the
listeners nicole then i'll let you go
what's the what what was question give
one last charge to the listeners here
um
no it's possible i think that was my
biggest obstacle was
not believing it could happen and
your mind is your most powerful weapon
in weight loss and what you tell
yourself what you feed yourself in your
mind
is what your reality is going to be i
love it i love it i love it i love
nicole thank you so much for sharing
your journey with us
for
man it's awesome just awesome awesome
awesome after two decades you said no
more
we're gonna make this right and shout
out to my man tony 120 pounds down his
wife thinks he's got 70 more to go i
don't know how many that is but i'll go
with it it's awesome guys
congratulations
ann kelly
song of the day
show's coming out january 6th
it's my birthday
so for the song of the day i'm gonna
sing myself
happy birthday to
me
happy birthday are you singing to me too
oh my gosh this is
[Music]
we make it cancel now that i've sang on
the air
pretty sure we're getting canceled
but hey
that was the song of the day
do we have to fade the music up
oh here come here it comes this song was
so good it didn't even have the end of
show music it's cool hey thanks for
everybody for being here kelly thanks
for uh breaking my picture
[Music]
thanks for seeing singing happy birthday
after a good prompting
ben thanks for being here
james evidently had to go to the
bathroom or wherever he went whatever
it's good to see you brother see y'all
soon on the dr john delaney show